monsieur le député voilà que vous
évoquez la question de demain ou en
vérité d'ailleurs même plus tôt d'après
demain c'est à dire ce qui se passera
lorsque nous serons prêts à procéder à
ce déconfinement dont certains parlent
donc personnellement je parle peu je
réponds aux questions qu'on pose mais je
parle peu pourquoi parce que nous sommes
en train d'y travailler
ça n'est pas pour demain aujourd'hui
l'impératif c'est de faire en sorte que
le confinement fonctionne l'impératif
c'est de faire en sorte que le circus
virus le le virus circule suffisamment
lentement pour que le nombre de cas
sévères qui justifie l'admission dans
les services de réanimation ne sont pas
supérieures au nombre de la capacité
globale de notre de notre système
hospitalier
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du
confinement et lors du confinement va
durer et c'est tout à fait difficile à
supporter pour beaucoup de français j'en
ai parfaitement conscience mais c'est
indispensable si nous ne voulons pas
nous retrouver dans une situation qui
serait pire encore que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de questions qui sont liées aux
déconfinement demain ou après-demain
beaucoup elles sont compliquées parce
que pour beaucoup d'entre elles elles
tiennent à des éléments dont nous ne
disposons pas encore à des réponses dont
nous ne disposons pas encore c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous nous préparons
se préparer ça ne veut pas dire que ces
prêts se préparer ça veut dire
travailler techniquement
scientifiquement logistiquement pour
être prêt le moment venu
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est un exercice difficile je les
dis nous en évoqueront les éléments
essentiels
lorsque les hypothèses sur lesquelles
nous travaillons seront vérifiés lorsque
les scénarii seront écrits mais pour
l'instant monsieur le député toutes ces
questions sont très largement prématuré
ce qui compte c'est de faire en sorte
que le confinement soit respectée pour
soulager nos services hospitaliers qui
en ont bien besoin vous le savez nous
savons tous de façon à pouvoir préparer
la suite